[Applause]
[Music]
yeah welcome back to another exciting
episode the Kos and in the background we
have a Powell girl probably one of the
most stunning DC characters that you
will ever see and in my youth that's how
I came across this character now this is
probably gonna be one of the long
longest shortest if it makes any sense
BIOS that I'm going to do B man because
it's convoluted it's all mixed up DC
Universe has always been weird you know
the acronym for was a DC dumb comic
right so I'm a Marvel dude always been
but there's certain characters in the DC
Universe that I gravitate to and um I
adore and love like the flash love this
probably one of my greatest characters I
like to be the flash when I was younger
um but let's get to power girl right and
let's get to the history of power girl
no this is how it goes and this it may
sound weird with this character DC
didn't know what to do with this
character she is from earth-2
she is super girl from earth-2 now if
this makes any sense deserve one deserve
prime right that's the earth that that
you guys know about in the DC Universe
with Superman Supergirl
Batman you know Robin and so on but then
there is earth to earth to is kind of
like the Golden Age heroes they have you
know characters like dr. fate and stuff
like that that I gravitated to as you so
going across these books is books that
you know I would collect I think was
like all-star squadron All Star Comics
something like that and I had saw her in
the team she is part of like the super
squad and then she became part of the
Justice it wasn't a Justice Society
where they had the guy who uses like his
time and stuff like that it was a really
good read it was good for me now as a
youth also she was the luck to us you
know she was strong she had Superman
powers but she was a girl and
as I got deeper into the character I
realized that she was actually
Superman's cousin she was actually
Supergirl
what happened on this earth is her ship
made it to the planet after this
Superman Superman had a faster ship she
had a slower ship and she made it to the
planet but she's the older cousin of
Superman so Superman was already aged
here when he got here and she came in at
the age that she was which was you know
a little bit older not too young and you
know well-endowed as a female now excuse
me so now you have this character that's
in the DC Universe and she gets a cult
following if you ever go to any of these
Comic Cons or any of these Khan shows
they're comic books I think she is
probably one of the top female
characters and cosplays and you will
like look around you see that this
character has a huge following
so what DC does every so often is the
retcon that day universe so that I think
was like 52 different worlds Pervis
right 52 different ones and they did
crisis on Infinite Earths
destroying all of them has his giant
cactus that they made up the villain
called the antimatter and then she was
in it so after all these herbs were
destroyed the character was kind of left
a limbo she stayed on her prime earth-1
and in in in doing that you already had
a super girl but
attack the so beloved power girl still
stuck around
so what DC try to do when the infinite
wisdom was give her a different origin
story are you insane
they tried to make up and then lanten
and uncle was a sorcerer who gave her
the powers and then this she had a baby
and threw the sorcerer do some
Immaculate Conception
total crap total destroying the
character but the character won't die
the character will continue to have this
huge following so get into how I got the
statute okay so I'm going through and
III you know me I can usually only
gravitate towards the Hulk or you know
door very strong masculine characters
because as it is a child you growing up
you looking at them and you want to be
these characters you want to see
yourself in these characters alright so
you know I really never you know like
Superman too tough you know I always
thought that you know Captain America
was more gritty more fighting and you
know he's still let you know that a
patriot type of thing so you know a
Captain America for that a school boy
thing but this statue
I saw sideshow had did a statute shout
out to Lewis am I gonna give his last
name but Lewis is a very good friend of
mine
we did some Statue training we met on
the forum we started talking about
statues that we had and he was
interested in the back of Batman Arkham
Knight that I have and the Deathstroke
so we wind up coming up to a deal and I
wind up getting several statues from
them and
you end up taking subway special for me
and it was a good deal all across the
board
well the only thing that really made
this deal happen was the powder now um
have a collective cart of Power Girl and
you know I was always infatuated with
the character it has a character
exhibited very visual you know i
pleasing characteristics you know for a
child so now when I saw the statue that
is I don't know you can correct me if
I'm wrong of his other statues that are
out there but I think this is the only
Premium Format statue of the character
and it needed to have it got it boom
there it goes and it speaks for itself
they have two different head portraits
as you can see the one with the cropped
hair and the one that looks kinda like
Captain Marvel with the head going up
man so you know which one how I'm gonna
display it how you see it right there
with the hair going up cuz I kind of
like that hair style the hair style
looks very nice the sculpt is great the
costume is on point and the paint
applications is insane so I'm gonna give
you just the statute please light file
and subscribe also oh we do it a new
thing right so if you go to Lourdes a
game and dotnet right boy runs a game
and darknet you go to loads of games net
and you go to the left hand side on the
tab and you hit the iron loves tab if
you hit that tab and multi things come
out you're gonna see Kos is going to be
up there so you can get old episodes of
Kos and you also see combat sopwith
camel which myself wanna talk about
fights but when you go to the Kos tab
you're gonna see that you can look when
you click it you can see all
their videos that I've done for the
statues now a lot of you guys have asked
me what are the dimensions of the
statues because you want to be able to
place these in to your Vestas or your
packs or all types of display options
that you're looking for so a lot of guys
need dimensions so what I'm gonna do on
this page when you go to the Kos tab on
low to get Minette you're going to see
the page now what I'm trying to do going
forward is give you a brief description
of the character give you the dimensions
of the statue sizes and stuff like that
and also try to listen that you can get
in for like you know what what's the
round the range alright so um look for
that so also look for combat talk with
the king that's myself that'll be on the
weekends also go to ILP bone this right
here you can listen to us talk about the
latest video games that's coming out you
can also listen to you know we have a
lot of good guests that you will enjoy
also go to the last word with low
kognito
and Evon setts for all the looter
shooter news and there's a ton of looter
shooters coming out that Borderlands 3
is coming you guys definitely want to be
around for that because they will have
all the breaking news all the stuff that
you need now without further ado I give
you power girl she should be called
power woman because they're nothing
girlish help up that
all women right there alright check it
out see you guys next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]